you've got to hear me there is no going
back you don't get your old life back
it's
over it's
over the the mission before you is what
are you going to build um what are you
going to build next what are you going
to build moving
forward and it's G to take a long
time that's not not something to be
scared of in fact it's the opposite it's
something to settle into it's going to
be a bunch of tiny decisions that you
make every single day they're going to
start to create new habits are going to
start to create new ways you see the
world and experience the world and think
about the world and the world thinks and
experiences
you and then you're going to make some
major changes